foreign
[Music]
but isolating at home was nearly
impossible the couple and their two kids
live in just a 150 square foot apartment
in shanghai paul one of hong kong's
poorest neighborhoods
her family is one of many affected by
the omicron outbreak that has swept
through the city and breached its border
and quarantined defenses
for over two years hong kong was able to
largely keep covet out but as of march
2022 more people are dying from covet
here relative to population than
anywhere else in the world
images of chaotic overflowing hospitals
and body bags stacked next to living
patients
this has become the dark reality in a
city living through one of the deadliest
outbreaks of the entire pandemic
morgues are full what is the end game
here the frustration the worry
since the start of the pandemic hong
kong has strictly followed china's
broader code zero strategy a suite of
policies designed to stamp out every
outbreak the moment it's detected
this included mandatory hospitalization
of positive patients regardless of
symptoms and aggressive contact tracing
closed contacts were also sent to
quarantine camps while inbound travelers
were subject to hotel quarantines of up
to 21 days
but with omicron quickly wreaking havoc
throughout the crowded city public
hospitals and health workers were
overwhelmed
[Music]
and so far our measures to contain the
spread of a disease remains a legitimate
and valid one the problem we are facing
is given the magnitude the
pace and the severity of this fifth wave
it has
outgrown our capacity
so how did hong kong go so wrong
the environmental conditions densely
populated housing yesterday was the key
factor
that lead to the explosive outbreak in
hong kong but what caused a high
mortality was mainly because of the low
western division among our elderly
roughly 90 percent of deaths in this
latest wave have been amongst the
unvaccinated particularly the elderly
the city also botched public education
campaigns and allowed misinformation
about vaccines to spread
when we first brought out the
resignation program the government at
that time was concerned about the safety
of the vessel among those with from the
illnesses
if you could dispel the misconception at
that time rather than asking those with
cognitive diseases to delay a
resignation people might not uh
developed the
misconception that these vessels are
very dangerous
hong kong situation stems in part from
beijing's decision to take greater
control of the financial hub following
2019's pro-democracy protests
on the one hand in the beginning of the
omicron outbreak you see medical experts
in hong kong suggesting it is too
contagious
it is not feasible to maintain a zero
code with policy and then in late
february and early march you see chinese
officials chinese official scholars and
official media in hong kong started to
publish articles of the article
attacking this living with the kovit
approach
the virus-induced chaos has prompted an
exodus and may have permanently damaged
the city's reputation as a business hub
so you see this kind of intensive
lobbying by the global business
community in hong kong and at the same
time the hong kong government has to
show their confidence in the china
approach
i have a very a good feel that some of
our financial institutions
are losing patience about
this
sort of isolated status of hong kong and
hong kong is an international financial
center
nobody attaches
as much importance
as myself to hong kong's international
status under one country two systems
for the city's poorest families hong
kong's failure in preventing the deadly
outbreak makes them fear for the future
okay